dania congratulations on your win you
were having one of those tournaments a
little loss here or winning a roller
coaster yeah whoa what's going on it
must feel really satisfying to beat
somebody of this caliber yeah i still it
hasn't settled in um i can't believe it
it sort of
only until you know until the very end i
thought that this has to be a draw
there's there's no way that i'm actually
going to win but
when i found that key line of my king
coming to d6 i'll show it a little bit
later
i started to get the butterflies in my
stomach i you know i realized when he
spent 15 minutes that my calculations
were correct obviously it's an amazing
euphoric feeling
the last couple days were really rough
but
you know my resolution this tournament
was to to keep grinding to play every
game
uh with with passion and with heart and
you know it paid off this time
is this the highest rated player you've
ever defeated no i i beat magnus five or
six times yeah just kidding yeah it is
it
is
it is i've only beaten one player over
2700 before this tournament so now i'd
be jeffrey and
fabi i'm the guy who calls the cops at
the party when everyone's having a good
time
all right well let's get to some
position there yasser if you had you got
it very nice and ready
unless you have something to say prior
to this moment i i kind of felt that
whitehead
played himself to this position like
he's two rooks two nights but he's
advancing
um
was this his maximum or uh
tell us
yeah so he thought um he played a
slightly different move order than i
expected it was all prep up the night
before
um
and i i didn't i remember that knight f1
is a move but um i didn't actually look
at it i only looked at queen takes p7
or sorry i only looked at d5
but okay knight f1 is pretty decent
yeah knight b8
after g5 and queen takes b7 knight a6
and the the knight reroutes to c5 and
black has
very good practical compensation okay so
i found knight f1 was was pretty clever
um
when i played h6 and he took my knight
at first i regretted it i didn't really
consider bishop takes f6
and then i think okay so it takes knight
d2 and here i think i made a very good
move knight a5 because if i had taken on
d2 then he takes with his knight and
then i thought white plays f4 and i
thought
you know it's i see the computer shows
equality but i think it's a little
unpleasant so i decided to keep some
pieces on the board
and yeah knight b1 was nice probably
white is slightly better
yeah i thought everything he did was
very logical
e5 rook e8 94 and after knight c4 i
thought um knight fd2
was what i was very afraid of initially
but then i played d takes e5
uh knight takes c4 bcde and very
important move queen f5
pinning the knight and he can't defend
e5 so i think black is able to equalize
then i kind of didn't consider taking
the pawn and the point is
after ed knight takes d6 uh knight e5
obviously i can't take it
and if i move my queen just anywhere
i'll lose c6 in the end so i play queen
f5
to induce g4 here i got excited because
i spotted this idea queen e6 and
everything works out so if he plays
queen takes c6
then i play knight e4 queen e4 f6
i was
you know i couldn't believe this line
was working but i think it does
so
okay so that doesn't work for white
he did what i expected it for no he
didn't do what i expect i expect him to
play knight takes d6 queen takes d6 and
knight takes c6
and i was very worried about a line
there it takes knight to knight takes c6
rook takes c1 rook takes c1
okay i can't play rook c because of 97
so bishop takes d4
and the point of inducing g4 is that
queen g3 is now a threat
otherwise he'd have 24. but i think he
stops calculating here but white has
knight takes d4 queen takes d4 queen c6
and i think i lose the pawn rook b8
rookie 8 and i thought i should be able
to draw this queen end game but this is
not my definition of paradise to have
this against fabi like a pawn down right
yeah i was gonna go for this and
suffer
when he played
knight when he played knight back i
think he underestimated the idea of
putting my queen on v3 and that's when i
realized that i might be taking over the
initiative
yeah because right about here once you
got in
the moves that happened yeah the game
wow c5 and
at first i i calculated all the way up
until that that ending and i thought it
was a draw knight c4 takes takes rook c1
is very strong
rogue takes c5 or sorry bishop b2 rook i
can't play roxy five because of knight
c3 so takes
rook takes c4 and i thought it was a
draw like okay he stops my pawn
then all of a sudden i spotted this idea
of getting my bishop to the long
diagonal i realize wait a second his
knight's tied down to the pawn and i
have this plan of bringing my king to
his pawn and if i take his pawn the game
is over exactly but here's the thing
after he played knight b1 bishop g7 king
f3 after king fate he has king e4
um
king e7 king d5 and there are some
beautiful lines here so i play
rogue d8 check right king c5 right rook
d1 right you know i might have to change
my pants but i think black is winning
here because there's a crazy line for
example if king b6
okay rook takes b1 c7
i play rook c1 and i promote with check
exactly the other move at first that i
was worried about is rookie four check
instead of
here
this gets my king to d8
king b6
rook takes b1
c7
and now not king seagate because it gets
mated but king d7
he has rookie 7 check
yeah the d4 is defended takes c8 queen
now i give bishop d4 check first
his game moves
i play rook c1
and i hide my king okay here he doesn't
even have any checks but if he moves his
king to a6 i go to c1 and my king hides
on g7
and i think fabi also probably
calculated this line and concluded that
yeah
oh yeah i even have a check so rook c1
queen b7 king of f8 the kingfield kiddos
when i spotted this yes
and
having realized that fabi
he tried to trade all the kingside pawns
but obviously that doesn't
doesn't work out although i think it's
the most tenacious
i mean when he played h4 i knew that he
had lost control of the game like we
both knew white was losing and i think i
played very accurately
i've seen him save some of these
positions before against dominguez i was
very careful not to rush and then i
spotted this idea of trading rooks
because after rook c2 and king c6 he has
no other good squares on the b file
before there's bishops e3 so
yeah so we trade rooks and obviously
that is completely lost
well done
very very very well done you've only got
two out of three i mean two
yes two and three you haven't drawn a
game nope
i'm going for the fighting index award
all according to plan
decisive gaze but
you're not doing so badly after all in
the tournament
no i mean like i said when you
interviewed me after my first win
i'm being realistic i knew i was
probably going to get in trouble in the
opening a couple of times
so i wasn't too flustered having lots of
randar is the game with alex is really
painful i'm not supposed to get in
trouble with white in the opening but i
did
but um
i'm having a good time you know as i
said before the some of the expectations
that i had for myself are i'm taking it
a little bit easier on myself and i
think it's
allowing me not to make everything life
or death and in a certain way that's
freeing me up a little bit to play the
kind of chess that i i think i play best
well i think anyone who beats the number
two player in the world
uh will feel like that tournament was a
good tournament no matter what happens
next but we don't want to see you start
losing games no no i have no plans
but i
i will not be resigning on move five
tomorrow i'll do my best to keep it
going all right congratulations on a big
win not just the win but the opponent as
well good luck in the rest of your games
thank you so much
anya celebrate your victory
absolutely
[Laughter]